دبلوماسيه التصريحات التي اطلقها مدير
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه تتراوح
وبحسب مراقبين بين الجذب والتهديد لطهران
كي تتعاون بشان ملف النووي جروسيا الذي
لبى دعوه طهران بزيارتها طالبها بتوضيح
اكبر حول برنامجها النووي
مجموعتان من الامور المهمات تجري حولها
المحادثات هناك توقعات كبيره بشان عملنا
المشترك من اجل المضي قدما في القضايا
التي تعمل ايران والوكاله على توضيحها
وتقديم ضمانات موثوقه بشان برنامجا نووي
الزياره التي تاتي وسط خلافات بين الغرب
وطهران ترافقها شكوك غربيه بنوايا ايران
تضمنت تحذيرا لايران بخطوره ما ينتظرها
وينتظر المنطقه في حال اصرت على رفض
التعاون لتحقيق مبتغاها بالحصول على سلاح
نووي وليس بعيدا عن طهران تتكثف اللقاءات
الامريكيه الاسرائيليه رئيس هيئه الاركان
الامريكي في اسرائيل يمهد وفق البنتاجون
لزياره وزير الدفاع الامريكي المرتقبه الى
اسرائيل
ويشمل هذا الحراك زياره لوزير الشؤون
الاستراتيجيه الاسرائيلي ورئيس مجلس الامن
القومي الى واش الاسبوع المقبل وسط تزايد
المخاوف بشان نشاط ايران النووي منذ ان
رصد مراقبون دوليون اليورانيوم المخصب الى
درجه نقاء تصل لنحو اربعه وثمانين في
المئه اي اقل بقليل من النسبه اللازمه
لصنع سلاح النووي
وبينما تستمر اسرائيل بانتظار ان تاخذ
الولايات المتحده زمام المبادره تفضل
اداره بايدن وبحسب خبراء طريق الدبلوماسيه
واستخدام العقوبات وسيله لنجم طهران عن
البرنامج النووي اولا وايضا عن تدخلها في
الحرب الاوكرانيه الى جانب روسيا الخطوه
الامريكيه المنتظره في اسرائيل يحذر
مراقبون من ان تتجاوزها اسرائيل فرئيس
وزرائها نبه قبل ايام من ان طول الانتظار
يجعل الامر اكثر صعوبه